le 27 mars prochain ce sera le retour de
l'échappée de printemps l'autre nom de la
roue tourangelle qui fête ses 20 ans cette année
une épreuve reine qui compte pour la coupe de
france et qui passera dans les plus beaux coins
de la touraine avec un départ de châteaurenaud le
parcours dévoilé à romain delville avoir 20 ans
c'est l'occasion de regarder le chemin parcouru
par la roue tourangelle une course qui a changé
de braquet diffusé en direct à la télé cette année
épreuves de la coupe de france professionnel mais
qui a toujours su garder sa fibre des territoires
cette année ce sont plus de quarante communes qui
sont traversés par la roue en 20 ans la roue a
bien grandi aujourd'hui le but c'est de pérenniser
je crois qu'aujourd'hui on est arrivé à un très
bon niveau avec la télé et tout maintenant c'est
de pérenniser le sujet de nombreuses années et de
préparer une équipe derrière moi pour pouvoir
aller au 40ème anniversaire le parcours 2022
c'est un départ à château-renault un grand tour
dans le castel renault des passages en pays de
gâtine choisi le pays de racan puis direction
langer villandry et l'arrivée traditionnelle
boulevard jean royer une course à laquelle jérémy
roy a participé trois fois jérémy roy qui fait
maintenant partie de l'association organisatrice
s'est ouvert ce parcours comme d'habitude en
indre et loire pour la roue tourangelle vera
des échappées par des tentatives un peu plus
proche de l'arrivée des baroudeurs des puncheurs
ou à ce prix ça pour vraiment il ya du suspense
jusqu'au bout 202 km fu panda 2 la bagarre
2022 c'est aussi le retour de la course des
cadets annulé l'an dernier 200 cadets sont
inscrits les champions de demain qui d'ici
quelques années feront partie pour certains des 19
équipes professionnelles au programme cette année